середністрокового плану пріоритетних дій
уряду І вважаю за започаткування такого
плану дуже
своєчасним академія керуючись законом
України про наукову і науково-технічну
діяльність щодо виконання неї
науково-експертних функцій здійснила
оцінку проекту середньострокового плану
підготувала і надіслала До кабінету
міністрів України пропозиції до Широкого
спектру питань державного розвитку
вирішення яких передбачено проектом
плану за браком час коротко зупинусь
лише на конкретних пропозиціях до
розділу 10 нова система управління та
фінансування науки на нашу думку ця
система має передбачати підвищення ролі
науки у розробленні та обґрунтуванні
стратегії соціально-економічного
розвитку країни і це могло би знайти
відображення не лише в розділі розвиток
людського капіталу державне управління
розвитком наукових досліджень має
забезпечувати не тільки комерційний
ефект а і зації національних інтересів у
сфері науки передусім це формування і
підтримка
конкурентоспроможних дослідницьких
колективів та наукових шкіл які здатні
визначати перспективи і вирішувати
проблеми подальшого науково-технічного
поступу не перелічуючи всіх пропозицій
академії зазначу такі це підвищення
мотивації вітчизняних наукових установ у
практичній реалізації власних наукових
розробок удосконалення та оновлення
матеріально-технічної бази наукових
установ налагодження державно-приватного
партнерства в науковій та інноваційній
сферах відповідно пропонується доповнити
конкретними заходами під розділ вісім
послідовність кроків це зокрема
розроблення дорожньої карти реформування
наукової сфери на період до 20-го року
про це вже говорила Лілія Михайлівна в
своєму виступі розроблення та
законодавче ухвалення плану поетапного
збільшення бюджетного фінансування
наукової та наукової технічної
діяльності та термінів доведення його
визначеного законодавством рівня 1,7%
валового внутрішнього продукту
скасування мораторію це дуже важливо
скасування мораторії на формування
державних цільових науково-технічних
програм вдосконалення засад їх
формування та реалізації На самперед в
частині спрямування результатів програм
на кінцеву готову до споживання
продукції тут хочу сказати що на
сьогодні назріла потреба у вирішення
завдань соціальногоекономічного розвитку
держави які мають міжгалузевий характер
які мо могли би бути вирішені шляхом
реалізації саме державних цільових
програм серед них зокрема розвиток
морських досліджень збільшення
наукоємності оборонно-промислового
комплексу цифрової економіки та багато
інших далі розвиток мережі центрів
колективного колестування науковими
прилада державних наукових установ і
вищих навчальних закладів про це говорив
шановний леніт Васильович на попередній
зустрічі з прем'єром далі розроблення
нормативпранової бази для пільгового
оподаткування операцій звезе на митну
територію України обладнання витратних
матеріалів та реактивів для наукових
досліджень це теж дуже дошкольне питання
Ну і закінчення зазначучи розроблення
цих таряду інших пропозицій проводилася
академія спільно з міністерством освіти
і науки ми маємо узгоджені позиції з
цілого ряду питань Ми розраховуємо на
узводжени наших дій і надалі Дякую за
увагу Дякую за представника федерації
роботодавців України пана
анатоліясть рішення цієї проблеми до
законопроекту про освіту стороною
роботодавців запропоновано окремий
розділ спрямований на реформування
національної системи кваліфікації у
цьому розділу визначаються професійні
стандарти як вимоги до кваліфікації
працівників кваліфікаційні центри з
метою зовнішньої оцінки якості
професійної підготовки випускників та
визнання результатів неформального
навчання національна рамка кваліфікацій
для розроблення та визнання кваліфікацій
у тому числі на міжнародному рівні І
саме головне визначається ключовий орган
відповідальний за роботу у цьому напрямі
Національне агентство кваліфікації саме
зі створенням і функціонуванням такого
органу ми пов'язуємо подальшу системну
роботу щодо підвищення якості
професійної підготовки Отже тут наша
пропозиція до плану пріоритетних дій
уряду на 2017 рік до розділу
модернізація професійно-технічної освіти
додати такий пріоритет
нормативно-правове забе бепечення
створення національного агентства
кваліфікації і крім того такий пріоритет
відповідатиме ухваленому урядом у грудні
Минулого року плану заходів і
впровадження національної рамки
кваліфікації на 2016-20 роки друге
актуальне питання забезпечення
ефективного партнерства між
роботодавцями і навчальними закладами як
у підготовці так і реалізації програм
професійного навчання тут наша
пропозиція до пріоритети дій уряду до
розділу модернізація
професійно-технічної освіти додати як
пріоритет впровадження дуальної форми
професійного навчання і наразі ми вже
маємо тут системну співпрацю з
міністерством освіти і науки в цьому
питанні третій пріоритет - це розширення
можливості визнання результатів
неформального професійного навчання як
результат ми отримуємо нові можливості
для роботодавців для швидкого
комплектування професійними кадрами
зменшення витрат на професійне навчання
у тому числі безробітних і підвищення
рівня формальної
зайнятості тут наша пропозиція до плану
дій уряду до розділу Сприня сприяння
продуктивній зайнятості залучення
громадян до ринку праці додати такий
пріоритет удосконалення механізму
визнання результатів неформального
професійного навчання підтримка
створення кваліфікаційних центрів
суб'єктів оцінювання і останнє але не
менш важливе забезпечення якості вищої
освіти Ми поділяємо стурбованість
громадськості щодо проблем
функціонування націона агентства
забезпечення якості вищої освіти і
зволюкаючи запуском повноцінної роботи
агентства ми втрачаємо довіру до реформи
вищої освіту в цілому на сьогодні як вже
зазначено в плані дій разом із
розробленням і впровадженням нових
стандартів першочерговим завданням стає
забезпечення акредитації програм вищих
навчальних закладів акредитації на
основі вимог які відповідають
європейським стандартам щодо
забезпечення якості Отже наша пропозиція
до розділу забезпечення якості вищої
освіти додати такий пріоритет
забезпечення функціонування
національного агентства і забезпечення
якості вищої освіти розроблення та
затвердження вимог до акредитації
програм вищої освіти відповідно до
європейських стандартів і забезпечення
якості вищої освіти до складу агентства
вже входять представники роботодавців і
з нашої сторони ми готові і в подальшому
підтримувати та долучатися до роботи В
цьому агенції Дякую за увагу
сказати що дуже добрий сигнал для
міжнародних організацій міжнародних
донорів те що освіта є пріоритетом для
уряду України Це дало До речі
спроможність міністерству звернутися до
єврокомісії щодо розширення доступу до
міжнародних програм збільшення
фінансування бо це вперше було
е ми відслідковуємо і надаємо весь час
звіти до Європейської комісії щодо
провадження тепер не тільки Болонського
процесу від яке завдяки прийняттю закону
вищої освіти До речі в спільній роботі
комітету профільного і Міністерства
освіти і науки було зроблено прийняття
цього закону Алей угоди про асоціацію
Україна
ЄС Там є окрема стаття яка також
передбачає реформування вищої освіти
України в рамках Болонського процесу
задля покращення якості вищої освіти та
релевантності і зрозумілості вищої
освіти щодо релевантності зрозумілості
вищої освіти України для міжнародної
спільноти вже певні кроки були зроблені
в тому числі і прийняття закону про вищу
освіту це європейська кредитна
трансфернонакопичувальна система - це е
перелік галузей знань та широких
спеціальностей
відповідно більшою мірою до міжнародної
стандартної класифікації освіти це
національна рамка кваліфікації що
відповідає європейській рамці
кваліфікації для навчання продовж життя
що також зазначено в угоді про
асоціацію щодо покращення якості вищої
освіти другий важливий напрям ее
реформування вищої освіти стандарти
вищої освіти Слава Богу готуються
успішно добре були сформовані на е
такому відкритому форматі
науково-методичні підкомісії з усієї
країни подавалися заявки на конкурсному
на конкурсній основі були с
сформовані вимоги до ліцензування
освітньої діяльності що з точки зору
європейського підходу було б краще
звісно інституційну акредитацію
запровадити але думаю що це в
майбутньому Як стратегія можливо буде ну
і нарешті Національне агентство
забезпечення якості вищої
освіти на жаль це
якраз виклик для
України
я нагадаю тут присутні деякі учасники
так званої ініціативної групи створення
агентства ми запропонували тоді до речі
в групу ввійшли ті хто сказав зразу ми
не будемо претендувати на вибори в
агентство були запропоновані деякі
вимоги до членів
агентства з урахуванням того що це
агентство які новації має запровадити Ну
наприклад знання англійської мови досвід
проектів міжнарод і таке інше таке інше
На жаль вимоги фактично були
проігноровані я говорю тільки про Факти
ми зустрічалися з членами агентства і
маємо чітке
уявлення щодо того який склад цього
агентства більше того Ну вибрали
державні вищі навчальні заклади навіть
державних службовців до такого агентства
нагадую воно має бути абсолютно
незалежним В своїй діяльності від
державної державного управління
потім виникли публічні суперечки щодо
плагіату деяких членів агентства і так
далі І так далі тому
е маємо сказати що незалежна точка зору
така визнання компетентності такого
агентства на сьогодні виглядає
проблематичним причому не тільки в
Європейському просторі вищої освіти На
жаль а й в Україні тому що авторитет
членів агентства і довіра до цього
агентства це є Ну просто беззаперечна
умова діяльності агентства забезпечення
якості ну маю зауважити що такий шлях
проходили всі Європейські країни це не
катастрофа все виправляється І багато
хто
перші першій каденції відпрацьовував так
сказати алгоритм роботи такого агентства
потім нарешті обиралися такі члени
агентства які виконували свою
місію тому якщо
згадати середньостроковий план
пріоритетних дій уряду в цій частині ми
можемо чітко сказати що неможливо в ті
терміни там заявлено 3-5 років
неможливо входження або навіть подання
заявки на входження національного
агентства забезпечення якості вищої
освіти до не до Європейського реєстру
забезпечення якості вищої освіти де До
речі урядовим членом є Міністерство
освіти і науки України з мого
року не до Європейської Асоціації
забезпечення якості вищої освіти яка
об'єднує такі агентства
Європи вбачається
можливим мабуть переглянути принципи
формування такого агентства в Україні і
здійснити можливо конкурсний відбір
подібно до того як в законі Про НАУ
науково-технічну діяльність через
ідентифікаційний Комітет з питан науки
наприклад таі алгоритм запровадити тут
ну і
звісно будь-які реформи потребують
коштів дуже добре що Міністерство освіти
тут фінансів також присутня і розуміє що
реформи без коштів неможливі в тому
числі і проходження процедур входження
національного агентства до європейських
реєстрів або асоціацій і щорічний внесок
на таке членство також мають бути
передбачені
дякую дякую хочу сказати що більшість
ваших пропозицій можуть бути можливими
для втілення тільки після ухвалення
закону Про освіту тому що і питання
національного агентства кваліфікації і
питання визнання неформальних
результатів навчання це все є питання
які розкривають і вирішує закон про
освіту новий закон про овіту тому на
2017 рік ми це не можемо включати тому
що запуск всіх цих питань можуть
відбутися лише після ухвалення цього
закону ми погоджуємося ми можемо це
вписати як пріоритети до 2020 року Дякую
і Дозвольте запросити до слова
президента спілки ректорів вищих
навчальних закладів України Леоніда
губерського Дякую шановна Лілія
Михайлівна шановний вчесла Ники круглого
столу спілки ректорів України ретельно
опрацьований проект середньострокового
плану пріоритетних дій уряду до 2020
року в якому зафіксовані важливі
державні пріоритети для вищої школи які
сьогодні постають як ніколи гостро
зокрема це стосується забезпечення
якості вищої освіти як важливого
чельника у підготовці
конкурентноздатного випускника
українського університету на Національ і
міжнародному ринках Праці а головне в
цьому - це формування довіри до нашої
освіти і важлива передумова входження
України до Європейського простору вищої
освіти адже без створення національної
системи забезпечення якості освіти про
це ми сьогодні постійно говоримо буде
вкрай важко зробити реальний поступ у
системі вищої освіти цього очікують
абітурієнти студенти А головне
роботодавці Ми сподіваємося що
найближчим часом запрацює Національне
агентство і забезпечення якості вищої
освіти якому належить ключова роль у
цьому питанні важливим пріоритетом що
окреслений У проекті плану пріоритетних
дій є утвердження академічної
доброчесності у вищих навчальних
закладах та наукових установах цей
напрямок дії програмі уряду Що позитивно
також сприйнято академічної
громадськості є не просто спосіб
формування Чесного академічного
середовища але й шлях до якісної освіти
і якісної науки
основоположним пріоритетом для
формування новітньої освіти є і
розроблення стандартів вищої освіти
відповідно до нового переліку
спеціальностей та компетентнісного
підходу при їх укладанні адже саме
наявність стандартів вищої освіти
створить умови для підготовки нової
генерації кадрів вияву творчості
університетів і змагальності серед них
щодо якості освіти провідні університети
схвально поставилися і до визначення У
проекті пріоритету щодо надання в 2017
році статусу дослідницьких університетів
переконані що прийняття відповідних
нормативних документів з цього питання
стане реальним поштовхом до активізації
наукових досліджень у наших
університетах спілка ректорів підтримує
і пріоритети у системі середньої освіти
наша країна вступає в етап кардинального
реформування середньої школи основи усіх
подальших змін у системі освіти
є інші актуальні проблеми скажімо
питання оптимізації мережі вищих
навчальних закладів забезпечення їх
сучасним науковим і
навчальнолабораторним обладнанням
фінансові питання тощо сподіваємося що і
вирішенні цих питань ми надалі будемо
підтримати мати розуміння і підтримку
збошу з боку наших міністерств і уряду
але безперечно рішуче підняття якості
освіти і наукових розробок у перш шу
чергу залежить від змісту роботи
науково-педагогічних колективів
навчальних закладів це наше найважливіше
завдання переконаний що спільними
зусиллями ми здатні забезпечені
виконання і цих завдань Дякую за увагу
Дякую леоніделягає будь ласка Ми маємо
так два ще додаткові виступи насправді
ми просто не можемо довше займати тут
приміщення зрозуміло
Отже Я
запрошую до виступу Сергія Васильовича
комісаренка Сергію Васильовичу ви можете
тут в нас є вільне місце А є мікрофон
шановна люлія Михайлівна шановна Віслава
анатолівич шановний Сергію
фундаментальна наука все інше - Це
прикладання використання фундаментальної
науки а от як вона використовується
фундаментальна наука в нашій країні Я
хотів би дуже коротко на цьому
зупинитися справа в тім що в
національній Академії Наук є дуже багато
наробок які лежать і готові до
впровадження але в нашій країні не існує
інноваційної політики фактично немає
механізмів яка б допомогла нам
впровадити на результати наших
досліджень я в національній Академії
Наук відповідаю за медико-біологічні
дослідження у нас створені нові
діагностикуми нові ліки Ну наприклад У
нас є діагностика протитуберкульозу як
людини так і ветеринарії проти дифтерії
проти загрози трамбоутворення нові
кровозупинні засоби нові ліки але Вони
лежать на полиці чому Тому що де наші
стартапи де наші спінофи де наші
інкубатори для інова для інновацій у нас
не існує що дуже
важливо податкової політики яка б
підтримувала потенційних спонсорів які
могли б поза бюджетними коштами вкладати
в ці наприклад біотехнології один
маленький приклад зараз з'явилася
синтетична біологія через 10 років
синтетична біологія буде головним
джерелом як в енергетиці так в
матеріалознавстві так і в
персоналізованій медицині вже існують
методи впровадження стовбрових клітин
людини в ембріони свиней щоб ми повністю
забезпечили людей аутогенними
аутологічними органами для
трансплантації що може бути
важливішим значить я знов повторюю про
те що нам потрібно розробити політику в
галузі впровадження досягнень
фундаментальної науки на благо нашої
країни в моєму інституті понад 30% є
позабюджетних коштів якби ми впровадили
те що ми зроблемо в інституті Можливо ми
могли б забезпечити по повністю наше
фінансування але по використання
позабюджетних коштів особливо для
устаткування для закупівлі залишається
проблемним Я на цьому завершую Хочу
додати до того що казали керівник
гуманітарного ліцею я вас повність це
аксіома якість харчування дітей в
дитячому віці в садках в родинах в школі
є абсолютно визначальним фактором для ї
подальшого фізичного і розумового
розвитку щоб ми не мали хворих людей в
подальшому Дякую за
увагу Дякую взагалі в цьому документі
прикро що вона не відображена в усіх
розділах тому що до усіх пріоритетів
практично наука може долучатися і до
обороноздатності країни і до
економічного зростання крім того сам по
собі по своїй логіці той розділ Про
науку Що і є він не лише стосується
людського капіталу а й ефективного
врядування тому що насамперед по його
назві і логіці вирішується питання
ефективного врядування в в цій галузі
далі Те що стосується самого розділу Він
має бути теж суттєво доопрацьований і в
цьому плані
Навіть легше з ним зараз працювати Тому
що ми маємо рекомендації європейського
аудиту псф і мені здається що і
формування проблемного поля яке є в
їхньому документі набагато більш вдале і
повне ніж в проекті урядового документу
і відповідно ті рекомендації що там
перераховані вони є відповідями на
Проблемне поле тому що якщо ми
подивимось на цей документ що є в ньому
неповно в розділі 10 Про науку неповно
сформульовані проблеми науки відповідно
навіть ті проблеми які сформульовані не
повністю відображені в наприклад меті
заходів які плануються І зовсім не повно
відображені в плані дій власне які уряд
планує в цьому напрямку зробити
наприклад те що стосується питання
входження до Європейського
дослідницького простору воно взагалі
відсутнє Як таке словосполучення навіть
АА далі а в перерахованих проблемах
наприклад і в кроках щодо вирішення є
наприклад створення Національної Ради з
питань науки та технологій але не немає
а фінансово відповідного організаційного
забезпечення і роботи написано хоча
європейські експерти теж наголошують про
на на це питання що вона не зможе
ефективно працювати далі реформа
а далі взагалі Проблемне поле так як
воно сформульовано воно деякі
маніпуляції містить Але разом з тим ми
маємо чітко сформувати що ми маємо не
просто здійснити державну атестацію 80%
установ чи прийняти нові
нормативно-правові акти в цьому напрямку
маємо суттєво переглянути саму систему
державної атестації систему оці ння
наукової діяльності як базового
фінансування з тим щоб те що сьогодні
піднімалось ефективно використовувати
гроші на базове фінансування тому що ми
не маємо право Перевести все на
конкурсне Але разом з тим національний
фонд досліджень не тільки має бути
запущений А має запровадити нову реформу
реформу системи оцінювання проектної
діяльності тому моя пропозиція така Ми
не бачили А ви казали сьогодні на
початку що є деякі доопрацьований
варіант цього проекту Мені здається що
повинна бути дійсно серйозна друга
ітерація яку б ми побачили на яку б ми
могли відреагувати і вмістити туди
рекомендації псфу з тим щоб цей план
дійсно мав Такий вигляд щоб спільнота
його могла
підтримати Дякую це дуже правильна
пропозиціярення і я пропоную як за
кожним напрямком знову ж таки щоб наші
профільні заступники міністра зібрали
тих хто можуть щось привнести до цього
плану його доопрацювати раціональний
спосіб і тоді ми вже будемо мати ту
ітерацію яку ми запропонуємо Кабінету
Міністрів для схвалення
на сайті Кабінету Міністрів є
перший затверджений перший проект Друга
ітерація буде на сайті МОНу викладена і
до третьої ми будемо доопрацьовувати
разом тому я пропоную всіх хто сьогодні
ще не зміг На жаль за браком часу
озвучити свої пропозиції ви будете мати
можливість це зробити в робочих групах
за кожним напрямком будь ласка
долучайтесь робочі групи очолюють
профільні заступники міністрів тобто за
новою українською школою
професійно-технічною освітою це Павло
Кузьмович хобзей за вищою освітою - це
Володимир Віталійович ковтунець за
напрямком що стосується наукової
діяльності Максим Віталійович стріха ми
будемо раді е вашій співпраці Важливо
щоб ми виходили на спільний продукт бо
якщо ми хочемо подати просто
альтернативні пропозиції які важко
врахувати в цьому документі не слід
забувати що в цьому документ ми
позиціонуємо пріоритети це не є
оперативний план Міністерства освіти і
науки це є стратегічні пріоритети які ми
мусимо виділити тому Запрошуємо до такої
співпраці я щиро дякую вам за участь в
сьогоднішньому столі і для
заключного для підбиття підсумків для
заключного слова тепер надаю слово
вячеславу Анатолійовичу
Кириленко Власне кажучи Шановні колеги
Міністр освіти і науки пані Ліля
Гриневич яка глибоко переймається
питаннями освіти знає їх має великий
досвід у цьому уже підбила ці підсумки
нам треба затвердити працюючий Урядовий
документ щобин щоби він був живим оце
головне тому із тих в принципі достатніх
речей які згадані уже в
середньостроковому плані треба додати
найбільш лушні пропозиції ми це зробимо
і затвердимо а діалог я знаю він не так
постійний в освітянському середовищі
якщо потрібно його якось
інтенсифіковувати То кажіть ми на рівні
всіх урядових структур будемо його
продовжувати але уряд по всіх сегментах
зараз проводить Ось такі консультації з
громадськістю і цей освітянський сегмент
як і прем'єр-міністр говорив і всі
зазначали він є дуже важливий в
діяльності теперішнього кабінету тому що
ми за цим чітко бачимо майбутнє і
гарантію незворотності всіх реформ які
відбуваються в країні тому ми з вами
робимо дуже важливу справу Дякую за
роботу і до зустрічі